c'était comment denver ça manquait de
chaleur
ici aussi la chaleur était moins torride
sans vous directe à la propriété
je n'ai rien contre un détour
[Musique]
je suis assez surprise de vous voir ici
tous les deux non non
beaucoup des bingos passe à la caisse
que vous faites dans mon bureau est ce
que tu te tapes dans son bureau
je crois qu'elle travaillait à la boîte
voici cristal ma fiancée je comprends tu
penses qu'elle en a après son argent
mais tu penses toujours ça des petites
amies de ton père
celle ci c'est différent
cette entreprise c'est ce qui compte le
plus au monde pour papa c'est ça que je
veux
dîner si familiale suivent la loi du
sang et les épouses elles forte comme il
arrive qu'elle ne verra jamais autrement
que la fille que tu as mise dans son
livre papa veut qu'on la connaisse ni je
vais avoir besoin de toi sur ce coup là
[Musique]
quoi que vous ayez trouvé
je peux l'expliquer
mal est fait ou va tomber à l'eau
pour faire [ __ ] cristal ma petite
chérie à peine moi maman mes cheveux
sont déjà assez compliqué je crois que
je vais beaucoup plaire ici pas savoir
d'où viendra le prochain combat
[Musique]
la guerre est déclarée
[Applaudissements]